all right patrick yes patrick where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally where i grew up
eastman georgia
tell me about your family mom and dad
uh dave's
dad was a salesman for mormon seed
and mom was a housewife
stay-at-home housewife
how would you describe your childhood
it was okay
uh
i think mom was too hard on me sometimes
no no crazy abuse
no
maybe verbally yeah i ran away once but
i was
i mean i was really young yeah every kid
does that at some point
yeah you made it through high school
no i didn't i quit and uh
after eighth grade
where'd you go then
i went to
the
eighth grade was in dodge county high at
a in the county school
and i finished that grade and went to
the high school for ninth grade
and i quit there
did you go to work after that
yes
what kind of work were you doing
i got a job at a candy i can't a canning
factory
where they canned uh peanuts
made boiled peanuts
and that's about it
[Music]
yeah at some point you got you got in
trouble with the law here
yeah is that what is that in georgia or
that was in florida that's in
tallahassee florida
yeah
tell me about how that happened
well
i was back in i was 35 at the time
i'm 58 now
what you want to know well i mean
let's set it up a little bit you were
married at that point yes yes
you have kids of your own no i had a she
had two kids when i married her
and what happened that you got in
trouble with
uh
i got in trouble with i licked my
stepdaughter's vagina
and that's why i got in trouble
how did anyone find out
she told them but you know she didn't
tell it tell them right then
it was five years before
went by
yeah
i believe yeah
so you ended up going to prison for that
yeah i went to prison how many years
uh
that had me at 65 months
and five years probation
i got out on my 85 percent
so i never got in trouble
in that kind of activity with young kids
was that was that something else you had
done in the before that
no
that was the only time i did anything
like that one time
yeah
how do you feel about it now
i regret never doing it i'm sure
but uh
the drugs i was taking out of time
didn't i think it made me braver
oh is that right yeah what drug were you
using
i was taking
xanax
if i didn't have xanax to have kalanapan
and stuff like that
because i had panic attacks back then it
started back then
so the medication you were using you
think
made me brave where i would do it yeah
but i could be wrong
so now you're you're a registered sex
offender
yes yep that's something that follows
you around for the rest of your life
yep it's hard to get a job
it's hard to find a place to live
you're staying in a mobile home park
here in
st petersburg florida yeah where your
all your neighbors are in a similar
situation yes yeah
how has this affected your
your relationship with your family and
friends and
your social life
well my mom passed away
my dad had already passed away but mom
passed away
right before i got out of prison
and my sister knows about it and that
basically i just got my sister my aunt
left
and um
my sisters actually proud of me because
i told the truth and took responsibility
for it
when they asked me about it
i
confessed to to it doing it right
do you feel
a threat to anybody now
no
you think it was just the drugs that
you're using
it could have been
but i had one
therapist say don't blame me on the drug
is that right yeah yeah received on
therapy for this yeah is that helpful in
any way
i think so
when i was in prison i took a class in
prison
then when i got out
i took a class once once i got out where
did they where'd you learn or how have
you changed from the therapy you did
well i learned that
the one that things goes in cycles
you start doing one thing and then it
cycles around it's harder for me to
explain it
i'm sure it's affected your
work
career and
your income and your quality of life yes
i was a journeyman plumber
and uh
had a
double-wide trailer and a piece of land
and everything got
took away
i'm sure that was the biggest thing in
your life it impacted all kinds of
it
messed up everything
yeah i wish i could take it back
but you can't
i'm sure it's hard to have
relationships with women now
yeah it's hard
i mean i was seeing
one lady but she was
but uh i was working with her too at the
time so we got to know each other like
that
and i told her i was a sex offender
yeah
what did that how did that change or did
that did that change the relationship
no not with her no
we did eventually start seeing each
other after about a year yeah
and so your life now you stay in this
mobile home park are you working at all
no no i got laid off
in 2019
and then a pandemic hit
then
then um
i was trying to find work and everything
but then pandemic
came
then they then i had a move
from where i was living at
because they saw the apartments i was in
then came back here
i had a heart attack in
in november
and that made things harder
then i in in december i had about two
bypass surgeries
[Music]
how does this all affect your your
mental health do you do you deal with
depression or anger anxiety
depression yeah
yeah
and at times anxiety
depression is the main thing
do you think it's impacted the young
girl's life that you
it probably did
i don't know but
i hope it didn't mess her up
you know what i mean yeah
because actually i didn't do it to hurt
her i loved her
what goes through your mind is you're
doing something like that or or is there
nothing in your mind as you're doing it
and it's just your
instincts or whatever
no there was nothing i wasn't thinking
about
when i was actually doing it i didn't
wasn't thinking nothing much
but then i
realized i shouldn't be doing that
yeah
was her reaction at the time her yeah
i thought she was okay with it
but when after that happened we never
i never talked to her about it
and
never i should have probably but i never
did
patrick what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
repeat your question again what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
the most support lesson
i know not to do that to people yeah
i should have respected her tomorrow
yes
what do you blame it on just the just i
blame it on myself yeah
besides the drug i mean
leave drugs out i blame myself
that's got to be hard for you to deal
with too
the shame of it all
yeah
it bothers me but
at least i did the right thing in a
minute
i didn't put her
going through court and everything
i don't know how many years ago
i did
five years
and five years probation
did you have dreams of doing something
else with your life when you were young
i'm sorry did you have dreams of doing
something else with your life when you
were young
did you did you have plans that you're i
did what i wanted to do i've always
wanted to be a plumber
so this derailed that yeah yeah
how old do you know i'm 58 58.
so where do you see your life going now
you're not united right now i don't know
i'm trying to heal up my chest
once it gets a little bit better i'm
gonna try day labor
all right patrick thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome i wish you the best of
luck thank you thank you
you